if you've been looking for a lively
stylish and thrilling series to pass the
time this winter then hbo max has an
early holiday present for you the flight
attendant the streamer's latest original
series starring and co-produced by the
big bang theory's kaylee cuoco is
premiering on november 26th
early reviews have been coming in and
the consensus so far is that the series
is a fun and titillating romp that's
been upgraded to first class
cuoco plays cassie a flight attendant
whose two big loves in life are drinking
and making bad decisions
during a flight to bangkok she meets a
handsome stranger and it's not long
before they take their flirtation from
the airplane lavatory to dinner and
drinks and then his hotel
it's a fun night but cassie wakes up to
something worse than any hangover she's
ever experienced
her date has been brutally murdered at
some point during the night and his
bloody corpse is still in bed with her
cassie doesn't believe she could be
involved but as the fbi begins to
investigate the case her hazy memory of
the night before makes it more and more
difficult to prove that she wasn't
the series is based on the best-selling
novel of the same name by chris bajalian
according to the first reviews the show
gives viewers an engaging mystery to get
lost in
as kayla cobb at decider wrote the
flight attendant knows that it's an
addictive cocktail of a show
and it never overstays its drama riddled
welcome cobb is far from alone in her
praise for the show
the first reviews for the flight
attendant have been largely positive and
commended the show style tone and
self-awareness
for daniel finberg of the hollywood
reporter one of the series greatest
attributes is that it plays to its
strengths
he wrote most shows of this type tend to
get weighed down by the clumsiness of
broadcast storytelling or the
pretensions of cable prestige
the flight attendant seems happy to be
enjoyed and disposed of it has a
confidence of identity that i
appreciated
digital spies david opie also noted the
series commitment to its particular
style
he said the flight attendant relishes
the camp absurdity of the source
material fearing between comedy and
darker thrills with gleeful abandon
the show's ability to mix nervy thrills
high-wire psychological drama and clever
humor was also lauded
according to nola ojomu of metro uk on
paper the plot could simply be dismissed
as a humorless thriller however there is
more than meets the eye as the darkly
comedic nature of the script shines
through
despite the largely positive reviews not
everyone was completely won over
writing for ign alicia lutz damned the
series with faint praise
overall the whole thing is just okay
it's perfectly serviceable filler for
those looking for a somewhat dated but
glossy comedy thriller that'll distract
you for a few hours the flight attendant
is koko's first big live-action role
since the end of the big bang theory and
according to most of the early reviews
she picked a perfect project to
highlight her talents
diane gordon of tv guide wrote cuoco's
choice to play cassie bowden the titular
flight attendant who travels and parties
internationally is a shrewd and
unexpected follow-up to the broad comedy
that catapulted her to stardom
even though cuoco is the star of this
particular show she's also surrounded by
a stellar supporting cast according to
critics
writing for comicbook.com janna anderson
called co-star rosie perez who plays one
of cassie's co-workers quote
a welcome addition to basically every
scene she's in perez received strong
plaudits for her sharp supporting turn
cobb's review and decider said of the
veteran actor as megan perez is
charmingly bumbling enough to make you
love her while somehow always feeling
like an unpredictable threat
you ready why do you look like norma
tesman
okay you know what i adore you in your
charades but i'm not missing the van
again
another frequently praised co-star was
girl zasha mamet who plays cassie's
lawyer best friend
cobb said that mammoth quote
consistently adds fun back into the
series most stressful moments
based on the early reviews it appears
that the flight attendant is flying high
so far
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite new shows are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]
you